investigators believe they might be a
step closer to understanding the motives
of Germanwings copilot andreas Lubitz
they uncovered new evidence from a
tablet computer found in his apartment
in Dusseldorf the browser fell off
vanished crushed the search history in
the browser had not been deleted we
analyzed the search terms used from the
16th to the 23rd of march according to
our results the user looked for
information about therapy as well as
about different forms of suicide on at
least one day he also spent several
minutes searching for information about
cockpit doors in particular on how they
are secured tuned wouldn't even see
shades for here when I was an undergrad
these latest findings leave little room
for doubt about what happened it seems
the 27 year old copilot took advantage
of his colleagues absence from the
cockpit and deliberately crashed the
Germanwings plane into the rocky ravine
taking 149 people with him to their
deaths meanwhile there were also
developments from French investigators
today the second flight recorder was
found by recovery workers at the crash
site this after more than a week of
intensive search the flight data
recorder records the route speed and
altitude of the plane should the data be
usable and analysis could give further
insight into the crash the cockpit voice
recorder was recovered one day after the
accident letting investigators here the
last conversations and noises from the
flight deck that box provided the first
evidence to imply that the copilot could
have deliberately brought the Airbus
down nine days later investigators now
think they might have a clearer picture
of why this tragedy occurred